Every bad guy in the world could be gunning
for the Brunners at the end of FUBAR Season 1.
From twisted love triangles to shattered secret
lives, let's break down how they got there
and where they go next.
Arnold Schwarzenegger is back in his element
in Netflix's action comedy, "FUBAR."
He stars as CIA agent Luke Brunner who is
nearing retirement.
That's when he discovers his daughter, Emma,
has also been keeping the same secret from
the family and working as an operative.
After discovering Emma's secret, Luke works
together with her and a team consisting of
Aldon, Roo, Barry, and Tina.
Their main mission is to take down an international
terrorist and arms dealer, Boro.
The group gets close a few times, but the
season sees them often having to shake up
their approach.
Turns out, their man is a bit of a slippery
customer who has his own network of bad guys
doing his bidding.
The other story of "FUBAR" is how Luke and
Emma's personal lives continue to suffer due
to their top-secret work.
Luke tries to encourage his daughter to learn
from his mistakes and not repeat them, but
this only accelerates her issues.
"Take your daughter to work day is going well."
She and her fiancé, Carter, break up after
she starts snogging her colleague, Aldon,
whom she has conflicted feelings for.
Similarly, Luke has his relationship woes
as he rekindles the romance with his ex-wife,
Tally, whom he has never gotten over.
There's a problem there, though: Tally is
in a relationship with Donnie, but she promises
she will break it off for Luke.
After Luke breaks her heart for the second
time -- in what he deems an effort to spare
her from further pain -- Tally takes the plunge
and decides she wants to commit and marry Donnie.
"FUBAR" Season 1 ends on an action-packed
note that ties up a few loose threads, but
also introduces a bunch of new ones into the
mix.
Luke makes a big call in the season finale
after Emma and Boro work together to try and
avoid the impending explosion in Sardovia
. While Luke has the ability to help Boro
out of danger, he decides against it, fearing
that he will come after his family later on.
"You gave me your word.
Let me out."
"I'm sorry.
I can't let you come after her."
Despite his closeness to the criminal as a
child and his previous reluctance, Luke leaves
the villain to perish in the nuclear explosion
and escapes with his daughter.
Back home, Luke announces his official retirement
from the CIA and gets blindsided by the news
that Tally is marrying Donnie.
Initially, he accepts the decision and wishes
both Tally and Donnie well, despite having
no plans to attend the wedding.
Emma eggs her father on, though, telling him
to fight for her mother and what he wants.
"I'm trying to be the bigger man."
"You're being the dumber man."
Spurned by his daughter's encouragement, Luke
arrives at the church before the ceremony
and tells Tally the truth – the whole truth,
and nothing but.
He reveals everything about his past as a
CIA agent, explaining how it was the reason
for his odd behavior all those years ago and
how he kept it a secret to protect his family.
Then, all of a sudden, Luke's car explodes
outside of the church.
It goes from church bells to Hell's bells,
as terrorists swarm the ceremony and start firing.
Luke and Emma pull out their weapons and return
the gunfire, revealing themselves as something
much more to the wedding guests.
A burnt-looking Boro reappears, holding Tally
at gunpoint and demanding revenge.
In a typical dastardly villainous monologue,
he discusses how he survived the explosion
and found Emma and Luke.
His nefarious plan is for them to shoot each
other in front of their loved ones.
"The two of you – the two liars!
– face each other, take your guns, and point
them at each other's heads."
Tally uses the medal that Luke showed her
as proof of his past to stab and unstabilize
Boro, who then takes a hail of bullets from
Emma and Luke.
However, both father and daughter understand
this is only the start of their problems since
their true identities have been compromised
and they believe Boro might have sold the
information to others.
A black van arrives and Luke, Emma, Tally,
Donnie, Carter, Barry, Aldon, Roo, and the
rest of the family, including Oscar Brunner
and his family jump in.
It's made clear that everyone's life is about
to change and they can no longer go back to
how it was before.
Luke even describes the situation as being
particularly "FUBAR" – f—ed up beyond
all repair.
"FUBAR" Season 1 is all about secrets and
the damage they cause in the long run.
It's also abundantly obvious that the lack
of honesty is behind Luke and Tally's marriage
falling apart in the first place.
She believes he sells gym equipment for a
living and is a generally unreliable human
being who lets her down.
Luke did have the chance to come clean to
her, though, when they reignited their relationship
in this season.
His plan for retirement was already in place,
so he could have been honest much earlier.
But he lied again
"You deserve to know the truth…
Barry has a gambling problem."
He puts her through the wringer yet again
by luring her in, and dumping her when it
becomes serious.
Then, once he realizes he may lose her forever
to Donnie, he unloads everything on her wedding day.
While it might sound like a grand gesture
to win her back, it isn't.
It shows a bit of Luke's selfishness and trust
issues.
He might hide behind the fact that he's protecting
her and the family from potential danger by
not disclosing what he really does, but being
a part of their lives and in that line of
work will always put them at risk -- as the
finale proves.
The least he could have afforded her was the
truth from the start.
He only told her now because she was about
to get married to someone else, and he didn't
like it.
The show features a lot of guns and fists
flying, but at its heart is, well, matters
of the heart.
The season finale leaves a question mark on
the status of two major love triangles -- and
no matter the outcome, some beloved characters
will be left brokenhearted here.
The first involves Luke, Tally, and Donnie.
Anyone can see that Luke and Tally share a
deep connection and it has never gone away
despite their divorce.
Plus, they realize the sparks still exist
after their latest fling.
Then, there's Donnie -- a nice guy who has
genuine feelings for Tally.
He might not have the bluster of Luke, but
he treats Tally well and is there for her
when she needs him.
"I mean, he's trying to replace me.
He's cuckolding the entire family."
"Please stop saying that."
With all three together now, it remains to
be seen if Luke will make a play for Tally
in front of Donnie, or if Tally will admit
her feelings for Luke.
In all likelihood, it looks like Donnie will
be the biggest loser in this situation.
Then, there's the drama between Emma, Aldon,
and Carter.
Much like Donnie, Carter is the secure, reliable
option for Emma.
However, Aldon possesses a more dangerous
and seductive appeal.
She has already cheated on Carter with Aldon,
and it's evident there are also feelings there.
While Carter and Emma may be broken up, there's
a hint they may try to work things out again.
However, Aldon might have something to say
about that.
After the gunfire in the church, no one has
much time to process what just happened.
It's understandable; the adrenaline must be
through the roof and they are more concerned
about their safety than anything else at the
moment.
However, once the dust settles, the noggins
will start ticking and questions will be asked.
Imagine how someone like Oscar must feel knowing
his father and sister are CIA agents and he
never knew about it.
Surely, he must feel a sense of betrayal at
how they kept this from him for so long.
"So you're all CIA?"
"No, just me.
And Luke.
And Emma."
Similarly, spare a thought for poor Carter.
He already believes the relationship between
him and Emma consisted of lies.
Now, this extra bit of additional info will
make him question everything about their relationship,
including if it was even real in the first
place.
Make no mistake about it, Luke and Emma have
a lot of explaining to do to their friends
and family here.
They won't be able to brush this incident
under the carpet.
Tina doesn't make it to the church as Barry's
date since she's wrapping something up at
the office.
She receives a call and suddenly, she switches
from English to Russian.
"I'll call you later.
I'm in the middle of something."
It's a shocking moment that leaves the audience
with a lot of questions about Tina and her
real motivations.
At the start of "FUBAR" Season 1, Tina arrives
on the scene as a transfer from another department.
She starts a romance with Barry and quickly
earns the trust of the rest of the team.
Later, she reveals to Barry that she is meant
to be transferred out again.
Undeterred, he pulls internal strings and
calls on a few favors to ensure she stays
where she is, so they can continue their relationship.
However, the big reveal in the season finale
indicates that Tina may not be who she claims
to be.
There's a possibility that she could be a
double agent and working with adversaries
to infiltrate the CIA -- including faking
a relationship with Barry to gain his trust.
Equally concerning is the identity of the
person on the opposite end of her phone call.
Is it her real boss or potentially the villain
for another season of the show?
Despite Luke and Emma's fears, none of their
loved ones are actually hurt in "FUBAR" Season 1.
They escape Boro's wrath relatively unscathed,
which means they are incredibly lucky and fortunate.
However, neither of those elements makes for
riveting television shows, so this is merely
the calm before the storm.
Saving all the main characters here, it's
a sure sign that there is major trouble brewing
down the road for the protagonists.
In essence, Luke and Emma haven't suffered
at all.
Boro wanted revenge against them for what
they did to him and for messing up his plans,
but he didn't succeed in the slightest.
The worst thing he did is reveal their secret
to their family and friends..
That being said, there is potential danger
on the horizon, especially considering the
group of untrained and unarmed people with
them now.
While no one doubts Luke, Emma, and the rest
of the CIA's crew's ability to defend themselves,
they are surrounded by regular folk, who make
the best targets for rogues.
"Oh man, I picked the wrong day to get high."
Unless "FUBAR" takes a drastic left turn,
it's likely the audience has seen the last
of Boro.
There's no chance he survived all those bullets
to the chest, and Roo makes sure he's done
by popping him one more time for good measure.
So, that's the curtain call on his time as
the villain of the show.
As Luke states, though, it's uncertain how
many others know Luke and Emma's real identities now.
Boro could have sold the information to the
highest bidder or even offered it up voluntarily
as a middle finger to the Brunners.
Perhaps he might have told a few of the other
insidious characters he interacted with earlier
in the season.
Alternatively, there's the real possibility
that Tina and the mysterious person she spoke
to on the phone could be revealed as the next
antagonists here.
If she has been a double agent all along,
this could be the next phase of some master
plan – one we may learn more about in a
potential FUBAR season 2.